hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
taten willst ich mache einen leckeren
kuchen mit bc haube und zeigt euch hier
für einmal die zutaten übrigens hat sich
bisschen was verändert und zwar hatte
weil man immer so hin und her gesund und
das hat euch ein bisschen gestört und
mich auch und deswegen sogar heute nicht
mehr sagt als er acht neue jetzt drauf
ja vielleicht
ok ich zeige ich erstmal die zutaten
also wir brauchen für den teig als wir
haben mit ike und brauchen dafür 200
gramm mehl 80 gramm butter 100 gramm
zucker fünf eier eine halbe packung
backpulver und etwas vanilleschote und
wenn ihr keine vanilleschote da hat
könnte auch eine packung vanillezucker
nehmen oder einfach selbst gemachten
vanillezucker und ihr habt
wahrscheinlich gemerkt dass ich ein
bisschen anderer mürbeteig und
verbrauchen mehr viele weise für die bc
haube und deswegen haben wir ganz viele
eier und benutzen einfach das eigelb für
den teig für die bcv brauchen wir dann
die fünf weitere von dem teig und haben
dann hier noch 120 gramm weizen gries
250 ca 160 gramm gemahlene eine prise
salz und eine prise zimt und ich habe 4
600 gramm johannisberg
ihr könnt natürlich auch andere früchte
nehmen aber ich bevorzugt die weil die
schön sauber sind und dann ganz gut zu
dem süßen bc passen
natürlich könnt ihr statt der harmlose
wenn ihr zum beispiel keine nüsse
vertrag nehmen oder mandeln oder sonst
irgendwas und einfach was euch am besten
schmeckt ich stelle die sachen für die
bcv einfach zur seite
und startete mit dem teig die eier
müsste jetzt trennen und ich gebe es
gleich mein eiweiß immer eine
rührschüssel für den für die
küchenmaschine und das eigelb in andere
schüssel und hoffe dass es mir gelingt
mein eiweiß kann ich jetzt kurz zur
seite stellen und geht jetzt einfach
alle zutaten führte in die schüssel rein
da muss man auch nichts beachten weil
das ja einfach alles zusammen verrührt
wird und jetzt könnte das mit einem
elektrischen handrührgerät machen oder
ihr nehmt einfach die hände und ich mag
das netz so wenig zeigt unter sind hab
also mach ich immer gerne mit
handschuhen
dann wird es einfach ganz kurz verknetet
und da ist auch deswegen gut dass die
butterweiche ist weil das ansonsten
etwas schwieriger geht
und wenn euch der teig zu trocken
entstand könnte einfach noch ein
bisschen butter dazugeben
aber es war eigentlich zufall so wenn
man ihn zusammendrückt dann sollte er
einfach zusammenkleben dann nämlich
jetzt eine springform mit 24 zentimetern
durchmesser gehen aber auch 26 oder 28
bei 24 werte kuchen eben etwas höher und
bei 26 oder 28 werde einfach etwas
flacher also das ist komplett egal
so wie ihr das einfach daheim haft und
besprüht es mit meinem back trance break
kann man aber auch ganz gut mit etwas
butter machen und da gebe ich jetzt den
teig einfach rein
das sieht zwar jetzt bisschen bröselig
aus aber ich drücke dir jetzt einfach
gleich fest erst mit den händen und dann
könnte er da so ein rand hochform und
wenn ihr sowas wie so eine teigrolle
habt könnte auch eine teigrolle nehmen
und der teig sollte etwa so einen rand
haben mit ungefähr zwei zentimetern
den teig stelle ich jetzt einfach kurz
ins gefrierfach damit er wieder kalt
wird und räume in der zeit kurz auf und
dann kümmere ich mich und die bisse
haube ich habe zwei weiß und gibt es in
einer küchenmaschine gebe da wenn es
klappt jetzt gibt da eine prise salz
dazu das hilft ja dass es schneller
zerstört wird also diese struktur und
dass es schneller eben steif wird und
bevor ich die aber anschalte gebe ich
erst meine gemahlene haselnüsse die habe
ich jetzt vor allem selber mit der
küchenmaschine gemahlen gebe ich sie
eben eine pfanne und lasse etwas
anrösten das muss man nicht machen kann
man machen weil dann einfach das aroma
viel besser wird und dadurch dass ich es
sowieso frisch gemahlenes genommen habt
haben wir sowieso ein schönes haselnuss
aroma und die gebe ich das rein ohne
fett lasse einfach in der pfanne trocken
rösten brauchte auch keine küchensparte
zug kam er dann einfach so durch
schwenken dürfte aber auf keinen fall
aus dem auge verlieren
und jetzt schlagen als steif und erst
wenn es komplett steif ist gebe ich den
zucker mit ab
währenddessen steht werde ich schon mal
so johannes kämpferin rissen abnehmen
und jetzt ist mein eischnee steigt das
sieht man hier das teilt nichts mehr
runter topf und das ist einfach fest ist
oder er macht einfach den test und
stellen das über kopf jetzt lasse ich da
einfach den zucker einrieseln und die
hasen müsste durch dann nicht vergessen
das riecht man auch wenn die fertig sind
dann richtig schön nach gerösteten
haselnüssen und das lasse ich dann
nochmal so etwa drei minuten rühren
aufgelöst hat also erkennt es dann auch
sehen wenn dann auf zuckerkristalle drin
ist
wie schnell ist steif und das ist jetzt
praktisch so ein baiser masse wie es ja
auch auf meinen pc video schon kennt und
estate mit einer küchenmaschine geht es
natürlich super geht aber auch mit dem
handrührgerät aber dann ist er ungefähr
15 minuten schlagen abschläge
das mal ganz kurz abkühlen hier und ich
hab jetzt übrigens auch johannes beyer
genommen weil der jetzt gerade noch
saison haben
aber ich bin ja schon ein bisschen spät
dran mit der johannisberg saison und
habe das jetzt noch ein bisschen
ausnutzen wollen
ihr könnt dann natürlich auch einfach
andere früchte nehmen die ihr zum
beispiel im garten habt oder die er
einfach im supermarkt findet im winter
könnte auch äpfel oder birnen nehmen und
bei äpfeln würde ich einfach auch darauf
achten dass es säuerliche äpfel sind
wenn er die johannisbeeren hier so
abgeht müsste einfach nur darauf achten
dass sie nicht zerdrückt also ganz
leicht nur mit der hand ab 10
jetzt nehme ich meine lbc masse und gibt
da einen weiteren griesheim meine
haselnüsse die sind jetzt auch ein
bisschen abgekühlt also wir dürfen jetzt
nicht mehr sagt heißt sein sonst fällt
der schnee auch bisschen zusammen lebt
da auch direct mainz impuls verein und
wenn ihr wollt ich glaube das habe ich
vergessen zu erwähnen gebe ich noch ein
bisschen bittermandel aroma ein geradezu
34 tropfen und dann schmeckt es so ein
bisschen nach marzipan wegen den
bittermandeln aber wenn ihr das nicht
wollt können das auch weglassen oder zum
beispiel ein anderes europa nehmen
das habe ich jetzt hier ganz leicht
unter
das ist jetzt auch fast wie sonne es
gibt ja so nuß makronen und haselnuss
makro und so eine masse ist ungefähr nur
dass hier eben noch ein bisschen kreis
mit drin steckt und es hilft einfach
dass der teig später ein bisschen feucht
bleibt und nicht so ganz wie ein baiser
massa wird zu trocken so dann gebe ich
die johannisbeeren rein und da würde ich
übrigens keine tiefkühlprodukte nehmen
weil die einfach beim backen dann zu
abwässern
ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert ihr
könnt ausprobieren aber ich denke
einfach dass es dann zu sehr durch
bessert und der pc dann nicht mehr schön
wird genau habe ich ja freunde sagt wenn
du nicht aufgepasst hat man kann ja auch
äpfel oder birnen nehmen und dann habt
ihr das einfach kurz unter und achtet
darauf dass es nicht zu sehr vermischt
ich will jetzt dass die b&c masse weiß
bleibt und nicht rosa wird durch die
johannes b
und deswegen nur ganz leicht und
vorsichtig gut und so sieht es schon aus
und schmeckt total lecker dann gebe ich
das hier in den tag hinein und wenn zum
beispiel die eier zu groß waren und ihr
zuviel bc masse habt ist es nicht
schlimm wenn das jetzt hier nicht alles
reinpasst und setzt ihr einfach mit
einem teelöffel kleine häufchen auf dem
backblech und können dann kleine pc
stücke machen das schmeckt auch stark ab
und ihr könnt auch stadt der nüsse zum
beispiel schokoladen raspel nehmen oder
wie eben schon gesagt mohn oder kokos
ich gebe jetzt auch nicht alles rein an
chips auch ein bisschen noch übrig und
setzt einfach auf dem backblech und
macht der kleine pc stücke daraus jetzt
nehme ich mir einen löffel und macht
also kleine wellen rhein in dem ich das
einfach so ein bisschen eindrücke und
dann stehen da wie so kleine mädchen
raus
muss also nicht mehr glatt werden und
tanzen auch schon fertig und der kuchen
gebacken werden bei 175 grad ober und
unterhitze für ungefähr eine stunde
auch bei diesem kuchen muss man ein
stäbchen probe machen also mit dem
zahnstocher reinstecken und wenn da
nichts mehr dran kleben bleibt dieser
fertig
meine kurven ist jetzt fertig gebacken
und ich habe ihn in der form 20 minuten
lang auskühlen lassen und habe ihn dann
mit seinem torten retter einfach
hochgehoben und da ich jetzt auch schon
eine halbe stunde noch mal hat er
abgekühlt ist aber noch ganz leicht war
und jetzt setzt sich ihnen auf eine
tortenplatte vorsichtig und jetzt müsste
man natürlich warten besser komplett
abgekühlt ist aber wenn man ihr steht ja
schon hinter der kamera und wartet und
deswegen schneiden jetzt erstmal an also
seda aus ihr seht auch die pc masse geht
im ofen bisschen hoch und dann fällt es
ein bisschen in sich zusammen und jetzt
gucken wir mal
und so sieht dann der fertige kuchen aus
und obendrauf das hört man auch das ist
so ein bisschen eine kruste und innen
drin ist er richtig schön weich und die
konsistenz erinnert ein bisschen an
marzipan aber schmecken natürlich viel
besser weil er auch noch früchte drin
sind und wenn du mir einen kurzen
schritt
samira gab dann monat noch schlimmer ist
angesehen und gesagt habe ich ja fakt
ist doch immer wieder stimmt ja also mir
schmeckt er kuchen sehr gut
wie gesagt kann man da auch andere
früchte neben heidi bayern passen auch
immer super und ich hab's letztes mal
mit mohn gemacht das war so mein favorit
aber ich glaube haselnüsse und ich
probiere jetzt auch gleich das rezept
findet ihr natürlich auch cell ist orson
welles de und die gibt auch bald
übrigens zum ausdrucken als pdf-datei
dass ich dann auf einmal ganz super dann
können dass er einfach abheften und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken und wünsche euch einen ganzen
tag gefallen